first off this is our new intern Bridger
so basically he's been helping us edit
some vlogs and do some VFX work but
today he brought in this crazy length
this is a 650 to 1,300 millimeter lens
at 1,300 millimeter lens is extremely
zoomed in it's like the most zoomed in
shot you can possibly get it's basically
a telescope without mirrors it's only
like $160 wait what yeah it's super
gentle we can't read anything on that
fire extinguisher up there but we can
read it through here Sam put your face
there this is actually really cool
because it's basically a telescope but
with the camera on it only your eyes are
framed of Sam I'll switch with you if
you want to come look at this yes that's
so lens like this basically it creates
like an orthographic image you can't
really see vanishing points everything
is just super like space is compressed
you guys want to take this to the
streets what if we put this lens on our
red camera okay good luck because I
think it will be actually incredibly
challenging we might have rails that can
extend this bar but nothing to actually
you mentioned you had a good idea yeah
this thing takes time like this we can
mount this middle part on the tripod the
camera here I can build a sort thing for
it and then the weight is still mounted
somewhere in the center albert is you
might be able to actually mount the
tripod head on to that so what I want to
do is I want to be able to put this
camera like down at the end of Hunter
Street and point it all the way down
past all the cars towards Santa Fe what
exactly will be legible if we do that
how far zoomed in can we get and still
get discernible things in the image
they're interesting we haven't done this
before some I'm excited Christian hey
man I have to take a phone call like
right now Carmichael is stuck on the
roof Jake he's not gonna last out there
there's him can you can you help him
right now yeah
thank you thank you please don't forget
first of all thanks to netmarble for
sponsoring this video and helping me
discover my new favorite mobile game
sometimes it's just like really slow
around work so like I don't really have
anything to do really helps me pass the
time but it's a highly addictive
open-world game and you can do
everything from quests dungeons battles
there's literally so many things that do
and explore like I don't even know how I
have time in the day to do anything else
made this sweet dual wielding warrior
character so I'm pretty lonely exploring
all the dimensions of lineage 2 by
myself but I hear this game's
multiplayer so I'm kind of in search for
a squad to help me battle these these
high-level dungeons you can pre-register
now on lineage 2 websites for free or if
you go to the link in the description
you will receive the hero starter pack
full of gems armors and all this other
cool loot that I've already been working
so hard to get plus if you pre-register
now you actually get to reserve your
characters a name ahead of everybody
else and you get an exclusive title so
if anybody wants to come join me and
play some of these dungeons hope that we
play with you soon but for now I'm gonna
continue this dungeon I feel like I
forgot to do something now back to
lineage
let's get your process alright use that
process that's secure it's a photo Pro
UFO curl oh these are the those cool
guys for NAB all right I like these guys
it's very sensitive right now in fact if
it stays on it moves the actual ball
mount is not locked that's pretty tight
now I assume I can keep rotating this
value called Jake did that works so
compare the size of this lens to our
biggest lens in our inventory the 70 to
200 millimeter lens and this is like two
and a half times longer okay I'm gonna
get on the one with Ren I've carried
more expensive stuff this lens is really
good for getting this heatwaves type of
that it's not a very hot day but I'm
sure I see some distortion of those
shots so now we have all of this range
to look down the middle of the street
that's providing enough support of
course so I'm gonna write the one wheel
all the way down there that guy it looks
like he's right in front of you dude the
cars that pass by the second acid give
us a clap we can see yeah yeah
know what the exhaust that's coming out
of the back of these cars is causing all
sorts of turbulence I can't even see Ren
I'm so far away like on this camera for
our fingers three all of them five five
so Renton when it clears up just go full
speed we're gonna try to follow you with
the focus right after this car what are
you doing
it doesn't look like it but there's at
least a football field between us that's
how far he was from he couldn't hear me
yelling I'm not talking to you we
thought you're gonna get hit by a car
every few seconds it certainly looked
like it oh my god like right here it
looks like I'm literally about to in it
this is the most insane Lin setup man I
wish we could go even better this is a
two times teleconverter
in this tiny little lens will actually
double the zoom of this giant lens 26
100 millimeter cool that is locked oh my
gosh oh my god this is so wiggly wobbly
no way
no way oh hey Jake whoa now you have a
real job
well your problem Esther how did I
become the prop master if this is what I
am to the world and the Internet then I
need to really redefine my myself hey
what's up amigo partner I'm the director
and founder founders but who say this
really a corridor digital please find
enclosed these awesome signs I'm sending
you to make your studio shine I'm a
longtime fan of all the hard work you
guys put in your videos I want to give
you something small back the hours of
entertainment you worked at a company
that makes off supplies like stamps and
stuff Jason Kidd lund thanks dude really
really progressive man and really
thoughtful thank you so much this can go
on the door I think it's time for
Clayton this is going on our door man
now no one will forget my name anymore
Oh quiet you Nicholas my daddy was a
carpenter but still that would have been
a crack home
[Music]
so we're filming at the same resolution
to kind of give a comparison of the 2x
scale and what that means
give us a sink mark by
[Applause]
you want to pay your dollar an hour that
was outside that does not count Ren Ren
we can see from your knees to right
above your head right now
yeah really it looks like you're
standing in the street the background so
compressed that the cars are just
swooshing by behind you and it looks
really like artsy like some indie film
what's going on just heard loud voices
yeah do we shot on a 1,300 millimeter
lens with a 2x converter what yeah it
was insane I want to see this I gotta
see this three two one I owe all my
success to Dobie Dobie Dobie is is watch
this get up in there get that weird ass
synthetic tentacle up in that [ __ ] Adobe
don't fail us now I can see Dobie from
here
no this lens can see Dobie from up to a
mile away
what is Dobie I don't know you said
Dobie first Dobie is the god of jade
Dobie is like this good luck
creature can't believe I have to remind
you Oh your SSD is cold guys
well guys stop moving for a second like
literally if you step or move it around
to Shyam be constructive Wow we should
get a new card okay take this hey hey
you be with you alright you gotta put
like iron sights on this right it's the
only way I can aim right now so cool
Toby would be hey Joey so there's
stairwell right there
[Music]
you're acting really awkward and weird
dude to young Jovi's well that los
angeles doesn't look better through a
however mean millimeters this is but fun
to play with Dobby is that God his
weapon is a wooden spear that's where
pool came from its fashioned after his
spear and that's how earth was created
did he know that Verger is Toby's
youngest descendant he doesn't say
anything I know he's humble
I hear there's some magic still left in
him
[Laughter]